[Applause]
i've got one [ __ ] life and this is it
it was not pre-ordained that i was going
to be a successful comedian touring the
world and being on tv i just i knew what
i wanted to do and then i pursued it i
was so broke and i was so stripped of
serotonin it went from being on the
cover of the paper to going you know
this is morally wrong i was having panic
attacks it's [ __ ] terrifying because
you think
is this my forever now and when you're
depressed it's the appetite for life
it's just gone
what's the thing that you're good at
that you could get better at that you
could be better than you last year
that's the key thing because take that
thing if you can find out what that is
for you
and then apply some hard work and time
that's your
luck be happy
i think it's a it's a powerful thing to
aspire to you know when you're on a
plane
and it's going down and the oxygen masks
come you have to grab your mask first or
you're no good for anyone else you being
happy makes the people around you
happier better for your friends better
for your family better for the world
[Music]
when you clicked on this video
i don't know what you were expecting
when they told me jimmy carr was going
to be on the diary of a ceo i don't know
what i was expecting
but what i got
and what i learned and the person that
showed up is not the jimmy carr that i
know from tv it's not the jimmy car that
i've watched on tv for many many decades
the jimmy car that came here today is
quite honestly
a genius
a philosophical thinker
an expert on the topic of happiness
someone that writes in his brand new
book about finding and pursuing your
purpose
jimmy carr has typically been known for
his very comedic
one-liners what he shares today
it's deep
it's profound
and when you find out that he was a
cambridge graduate
it kind of makes sense
because jimmy is a very very smart man
not just book smarts
he's life smart
this podcast today is one of my favorite
of all time because it has everything
not just those profound truths that i
know i know will change your life but
also
a very remarkable compelling vulnerable
personal story
one that starts with his mum and his dad
when that starts with dyslexia and
feeling rejected at a very young age
one that journeys through being
cancelled controversy panic attacks
depression
and ultimately finding himself
he says it himself
this is the jimmy car you don't know
but i'll tell you this
this is the jimmy car you should
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the direva ceo i
hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
it's so funny because every time i do
this podcast i was trying to think of a
new place to start but having read your
story and having read the stories of my
guests before they arrive i always end
up starting in the same place so i was
just sat there trying to think of a new
way to to come into it but
i'm gonna go for it so
your childhood jimmy very very pivotal
and i was reading
throughout your childhood about these
really really pivotal moments pivotal
moments of changing school and family
and mum and dad
take me to the the most important
context from your childhood i suppose i
mean listen it's it's when you remember
stuff we're all um
unreliable narrators when we look back
on our lives and i think the gift of
lockdown was that uh memory and speed
are inversely proportionate that when
you slow down in life you remember more
you kind of and it's a great time for
kind of recalibration and thinking well
what happened so the things that i
recently became a father so you're
thinking about childhood again in kind
of this new way and thinking well what
are the what are the things you would
want for your child
what would you want to give them and
also what were those key moments where
you get to decide who you are and i
think that the key bits in my childhood
were the moments where you become aware
you are a story you tell yourself
so i moved schools when i was 16 and i
was kind of not a tear away but i was in
trouble and i was messing around and i
was with a uh
a fairly rough crew
and i switched schools and told a
different story not to be
machiavellian you just kind of arrived
at the new school and went well i guess
i guess maybe no one no one knows me
here i could just be whoever i want to
be and you become aware of how
not consciously but even at that early
age aware that you're not a noun you're
a verb you're a doing thing and you can
do things differently and you can do
better
and then so
that lesson obviously that you then
forget that
and you don't make good on that again
for a while so i was kind of in my
mid-20s when the next big kind of sea
change of going right i'm gonna leave
uh a job working for someone and go on
on an adventure and it was i mean for me
that kind of mid-20s thing was it's not
childhood
but it feels like even at 25 i was
um
in an archetypical way still a child
because i was living my life for someone
else i hadn't really taken the reins yet
i hadn't really made a decision until i
was in my mid-20s so it felt like to me
i was like a big kid when i was 25. and
then suddenly at 26
yo ho ho a pirate's life for me i just i
[ __ ] off and joined the circus and
became a comedian and started leading my
own life in a way i think i mean part of
the reason for the book is i think a lot
of people aspire to that a lot of people
want to
um
want to find their purpose
and they want to they want to pursue it
and you know
it's very sad a lot of people don't get
to do either
and when you change school at 16 years
old and you talk about you were able to
kind of shed this identity that that
school and environment and the teachers
there had given you well i think you've
got baggage haven't you when you're even
when you're 16 you've got baggage you're
going to sixth form and you're oh you're
the tearaway kid you're going to do like
that you're going to do
you know this well in your exams it's
it's a
um your past indicates where your future
is going to go and it doesn't have to be
that way at some stage you just have to
you you cut those
apron strings or you cut with the past
and go no i could be academic
you know i'm i'm a i'm very dyslexic and
i didn't really learn to read and write
till i was about maybe 10 or 11 with any
level of proficiency and then i managed
to get myself to cambridge and part of
that is like a
force of will you just go right i'm
gonna i'll do that i'll figure out how
to do it i'll figure out what the code
is and often i think it's that thing of
like the thing that comics do incredibly
well i talk about like the super powers
of comedians what comedians do
brilliantly is they're great at pattern
recognition and that strikes me as like
the most important thing in life for
humans is pattern recognition well that
kind of works like that how do you write
an a grade essay it's not about knowing
about history it's about knowing the
structure of what that essay looks like
and so you kind of lift the structure
and go right well i'll just
i'll i'll write to that formula
crack in the code
on stuff and i think at every level
you're trying to crack new codes you're
trying to get better at stuff
and do you think if you go back to that
that changing school scenario again you
were given this identity and that
identity came with a set of like
implicit instructions on who you were
which we then all
for some reason subconsciously believe
and then obey and then we start
fulfilling 100 i mean i think the
the the things that dictate our lives
are our beliefs
your life is as good as your you believe
it's going to be i think i'm a real
advocate that disposition is more
important than position and 95 of life
is how you look at it and 5 is what
happens to you so the idea that you go
what what are you going to believe well
most of our beliefs the beliefs that
really affect us are the um
presuppositions that we make we don't
even think about them we just think it's
oh i'm not the kind of person that does
that
i'm not the kind of person because i'm
not from that background or i'm not i'm
not from sherbes i don't know anyone in
showbiz so i'm never going to be in
showbiz and then you allow yourself at
some stage you go well [ __ ] that i'm
going to allow myself to dream or to to
uh to try and be more than but you know
the premise of the book kind of is
there's nothing special about me
it was not preordained that i was going
to be a successful comedian touring the
world and being on tv that was not like
a lock
i don't have a a irrefutable talent i
just i knew what i wanted to do and
you know what do you want being the key
question in life and then i pursued it
kind of doggedly because i i found my
purpose
and that strikes me as something that's
um
achievable not you know i'm not
suggesting everyone goes out and becomes
a comedian but i want better lives for
everyone
i read um
i read that you said
you spent a lot of time
cheering your mother up
yeah i think most comics i mean the
cliche is the comedian is depressed
right that's the go-to and it's such a
pleasing irony why wouldn't it be
because you go over there he's makes us
laugh
but uh he's really down
you know the old uh
you know the old story there's an old
joke about a guy's like
super depressed like he's gonna kill
himself he's really down and he goes to
see a psychiatrist and the psychiatrist
says well you need to
you know you need to cheer up grimaldi
is in town the great clown grimaldi is
in town he's the greatest clown the
world has ever seen he's i saw him last
he's hilarious you won't even be able to
breathe because you'll be laughing so
much and you'll forget your worries and
you'll just be happy again
and the guy goes
but i am grimaldi
the great old joke about you know it's
like okay tears of a clown thing i think
it's parents i think my mother was
if you talk to communities you'll talk
to a lot of comedians on this podcast
right so
i think the question to ask is which
parent was sick it it tends to be you
know one of them and it tends to be
either physical or mental with my my
mother was depressed you don't know that
when you're a kid you just you know
something isn't right you know you have
to the atmosphere has to be
changed
so you become very good at um at
changing people's states
and then that becomes your job you lean
into that that becomes a very important
thing that you place a lot of value on
now i hadn't put that together till i
was in my mid-20s
but the idea of going being able to
change people's states is a it's a it's
an interesting skill set i mean i like
to think of myself as a drug dealer
but i'll never be taken by the feds
because the drugs are already on you
you've got the the endorphins there
you've got the good [ __ ] in there and
it's about letting that out in a very
um
sort of organic
natural high of laughter
and i'm a huge advocate of live comedy
because people laugh so much more
when they're in a crowd it's a it's a
social noise it's very tribal it's the
idea of like we all belong to this thing
if you watch your favorite show on on
the phone on the bus
and you'll smile and it won't do you any
good
physiologically but if you see it in a
crowd of 30 people with all your friends
around it's like
laugh you cry laughing i guess that's
why they put canned laughter on tv i
think to encourage yeah to encourage i
mean they can laughter things slightly a
myth but yeah they they uh
uh they do you know and it does
encourage you to kind of do a little bit
but it's
um it's really about that thing of it
being a tribal thing where we we sort of
want to belong and laugh with something
and i kind of feel that as a comedian
you're part of a very long tradition
there's always been comics you know
there was comedians and there's variety
acts and then there's court jesters and
then there's trickster gods
uh you know nancy and the monkey king
and all these guys all these things from
our sort of deep-rooted culture there's
always someone
saying the other
slightly outside looking in
um
i think being an immigrant i think is an
important thing with that i mean i don't
read as an immigrant in any way shape or
form
it's the average white guy but and i
sound like i was privately educated but
it's interesting in the book of like
people's perception of you you have to
be aware who you are
and you have to be aware how you're
perceived they're both important and you
i think acceptance of that is like a
it's like that thing of what's the first
step on the journey to finding your
purpose it's like we have to know who
you are you have to start with like
there's an honesty to comedy of going
right this is what i've got
going back to that the first person you
were sort of
i guess assigned to chair up which was
your mother what was
did you know at the time she was
depressed no i just thought it was
normal i mean genuinely like
night she was a lot of fun and she was
very charismatic and people liked her i
sort of could see that and then you
could see people are complex and nuanced
and you could see that she was you know
she didn't get out of her dressing gown
most days she didn't
she she wasn't engaged in in a way that
was normal she didn't take care of
herself um and
it's a great sadness you know you kind
of look back and you feel a bit guilty
that maybe you could have done more or i
think even the debate now the culture
that we that we have at the moment where
people are talking about mental health
and they're talking about getting help
and what to do and talking therapies
it feels like there's a whole world
that's open now that maybe things might
have been different if if it had been
you know 20 years later
but it felt like she was quite isolated
and and depressed
one of the things you you talk about
linking to that is the
the root cause of a lot of things you
know mental ailments depression um
addiction is the lack of a lack of
purpose
and it's a you know like hazarding a
guess at what the causes would be and
with depression um
it somewhat bizarrely seems to be quite
generational at times did you ever
figure out or hazard a guess in your
later life what caused her to feel the
way she did
i make a lot of cases in the book for
conflated words like you know words that
you sort of think they mean the same
thing but they don't there's that sort
of a theme in the book of sort of going
well i think happiness and pleasure are
different and i think um
envy and jealousy are different and i
think uh
depression and sadness are very
different
i think some of it was circumstantial
which which is sadness
and this you know sadness is better if
you could choose between sadness and
depression go with sadness because it's
circumstantial it's about uh it's about
nurture it's about what's going on in
your world who you're worth what's going
what's happening that's getting you down
okay but depression is a much more
serious thing there'll be people
listening to this or watching this that
suffer with depression it's a serotonin
imbalance in the head it's a proper
medical ailment and we never think of it
like that we never think of it like that
right you've never told anyone with uh
cancer snap out of it come on come on
let's snap out of it let's go and get a
drink come on cancer come on
but somewhat depressed
you've
been 100 people have done that come on
you're depressed come on we're going to
get a drink we're going you've got
nothing to be depressed about i'll tell
you what's great you know you do that
and you go it's so crazy when you stop
and think about
suicide as a symptom of depression not
as a thing that's a stand alone it's
just there's an epidemic of it going on
and people aren't taking it seriously
it's it's uh
it's i think comedy is a very valuable
tool as well because
it lends perspective
and really what is suicide it's a it's a
it's a
it's a permanent solution to a temporary
problem
it's so sad you know when you hear about
young people that's it's just it's a
heartbreaker
and i think often that thing of like
purpose is the
is the cure
do you think
yeah so what i don't know why i'm asking
this question because these are these
are you know these are very complex
questions specifically around mental
health but i i think
all of these questions come from my own
place of like deep deep curiosity um as
it relates to to mental health the
apparent increase in it in our society
whether that's because more people are
you know labeling it or because they're
more people are actually going through
those um those elements well i think
there's i think there is a um
[Music]
you know if we take it over you know not
a huge not geological time but over like
a 30-year time plan uh what's happened
the last 30 years well it's the rise of
the individual
right we've all become
uh the individuals become more powerful
and the group or the tribe has become
less powerful and that is not only a
force for good
there's a negative to that as well so
people feel their families are smaller
um groups are smaller people feel like
they go their own way so we've never
been more connected and felt more
alienated it's you know set up to to
fail almost there's a generation of
people that feel like they're incredibly
connected and they have
a huge number of friends online
but they have no one to talk to
and that's a it's a it's a that's a
difficult thing and they don't feel
maybe part of a group they always feel a
little bit other so that's you know if
you there's a great book called selfie
and a great book called tribe i remember
sort of reading them back to back and
thinking yeah this something's going on
here and why do why does everyone want
to go to glastonbury
why does everyone want to go to a music
festival
it's not necessarily because they you
know i love that song you see that song
anyway you play that song on your
headphones but they want to feel part of
something and they want to be in a crowd
with other people and feel a sense of
belonging there's there's something a
little bit our society is unbelievably
great
and i love that kind of stephen pinker
enlightenment now thing about right it's
the best it's ever been there's [ __ ]
terrible things happening but it's the
best it's ever been i love that positive
attitude but there are serious issues
especially i mean it seems especially
for young people it seems like it's um
i mean part of the reason to write the
book is i have a son but also the people
that come and see my shows and the
people that go well i don't
i don't know what to do
and yet
you know and they come out for a laugh
or whatever and you go well i'm not i'm
the jester here i don't have any answers
but
this is what worked for me so sharing
that felt like a
really sort of privilege to be able to
do that and you think about
your life and your childhood and the
people that you met along the way that
made huge differences with seemingly
small interventions
the world seems to be hurtling more and
more in the direction of individualism
loneliness i mean the stats would back
that up that we're getting more and more
lonely as we're moving online and you
know facebook announced they're changing
their name to meta last week and they're
you know building the metaverse which
we're all going to live in and it's
interesting how empathetic and beautiful
people are one on one
you know if you you've ever met someone
one-on-one that cancel culture is an
interesting thing to talk about right
because i get cancelled at some stage in
the next two years
it just happens let's just accept that
for a joke i've done online it's already
out there it's pointless me worrying
about it but that thing of like
one-on-one with people people are
incredibly empathetic and kind and
there's a thing that we're doing now
where we're not on a zoom core we're
across the table for each other looking
into each other's eyes having a
conversation there's an intimacy to that
there's like a there's like a okay we're
gonna have a conversation here and we're
gonna see each other's points of view
and we're gonna talk about it and it's a
it's
there's something about this that goes
back
10 000 years like people have always
done this the online thing you what what
are we missing from that with that that
immediacy and i think the the crisis in
lockdown where people were literally
locked down and shut away it's just it's
not good for us how do we change it
well i don't know i mean i think there's
i i don't know is is the answer i mean i
think there's
the really simple [ __ ] is is not getting
done
for me because it feels like this big
boat that's going in one direction and
it's speeding up
and what i mean by that is we're
actually building our lives into the
digital space which is making us more
socially connected
online but more disconnected in the real
world it's an interesting thing going on
i mean i it's interesting and terrible
um where people are i sort of quote a
lot in the book i use a lot of quotes
because i sort of think quotes are the
truth like it's everything else has been
burnt away there's nothing left but
these six or seven words that just sum
something up and you go that's just
[ __ ] that's stuck around for 50 years
for a reason that's just [ __ ] true
so the i think it's eleanor roosevelt
that said you know comparison is the
thief of joy
which i love
because we're comparing our lives to
everyone else right we're the classic
you know
millennial kind of phrase of like you're
comparing
your insides to someone else's outsides
but even there's another thing layered
on top of that now where i don't know
you online but you have an online
profile and you might well be jealous of
yourself online
because you look at your pictures of
yourself online and you're always
smiling and you're always with beautiful
people drinking a cocktail on a beach
beautiful car beautiful thing that thing
of like you can't you're disconnecting
with how you feel
and how you put you choose to express
yourself digitally
um so that there's it's a it's an odd
thing that's that's happening i think
like
feeling connected to other people and
laughing with other people i think it's
here's how we fix it right it's nature
and nurture
right so oldest debate in the world
nature nurture what's important well who
[ __ ] cares nature's the cards we were
dealt right that's what we got we got
this i got this you got that okay all
right you win so
so but that thing of going the nature
nurture thing is right you got the
nature that's fine that's the cards how
you going to play it is the nurture and
i think there's a perception that
nurture is finished at
15 18 20 21 at what stage do you think
you're done i'm done off to the world
now gonna kill it like it's a nonsense
nurture is like an ongoing process of
like and thinking about it giving it
even five minutes thought of going right
who do i like and why do i like them
well i like i like who i am with people
that's why i like them
so
when i'm with my child i like who i am
when i'm a dad i like playing that role
i like being that part i like i like who
i am when i'm with my friend johnny and
we chat about music i like who i am when
i'm with you know my my friend uh matt
and we're chatting about aliens and what
you know those things and spending
finding more time with those people and
laughing and connecting with the people
that make you happy
that seems to be the
the you know the smart thing i mean that
you know i suppose there's simple [ __ ]
like you know
putting your phone away for a day have
you ever done that we did it on our last
holiday
i haven't had a holiday for two years
yeah but that thing like we put our
phones in we checked the phone in the
morning to see no one interesting's died
right you don't want to miss a biggie
you know what i mean you don't want this
[ __ ] diana too whatever the [ __ ] so
you put the phone in the safe in the
morning and then you have your day and
then you check it in the evening you
give yourself the
the rush of i've got so many emails oh
my god
and and then it's it's interesting
though of that
that feeling of decompressing and most
people don't don't have that not that
you know it's not i'm not saying that
digital world is
you know a terrible thing and it's
clearly the way we're going so we have
to learn to live with that
we talked there about one half of your
parental equation
tell me about the other half
well you know i've just become a father
and i'm acutely aware that it doesn't
always work out i haven't seen my father
in 20 years i guess
um it's a long time
um and i i don't have a relationship
with him and
listen there's there's three stories
mine and yours and then the truth um
but that's the facts of the matter is i
don't have any relationship with my
father so
that makes me um that's another lesson
in life though isn't it she go right if
you don't have a father
don't be a dummy about it don't not have
a father just find a different one
that archetype is so important to our
development having a mother is you know
my mother died i didn't go well i guess
you know the older
female nurturing
um
archetype i just i guess i'll live
without that you go you find other
people that are maybe not one other
person but you find uh you put your team
together you put your nurture together
and you you go well i need to find those
people you need to find i mean i suppose
i'm lucky in the the job that i do that
you have certain you know people are
further down the road
so if you look to them as kind of
mentors or you look to them as as uh as
people that you want to impress and you
want to you know you're aware of that
what you need
and now you've had a son yeah that must
be uh
you know there was two things you talked
about that real really really pivotal in
recent times one of them was the
pandemic and the other one was obviously
the birth of your of your own son what
are the the top level you know shifts
that have occurred in you because of
those two events
i suppose i mean i got i was kind of
late to fatherhood i think because um
i think it was i think psychologically i
think maybe i didn't want to be
i didn't want to be a father because i
didn't want to be my father
and you know so you find a different way
through you find different models you
know i've got friends that are
incredible fathers
and you kind of model that and it's that
thing of like
it's what humans do we kind of go well
okay well i could kind of do that i
could see what he's doing there and
that's amazing so that felt like
i mean it's such a
i mean everyone does it's like not a big
deal that i've had a kid but it it's a
big deal in my life obviously it's like
it's uh
it's there's a quote in the book i love
quotes um it's like having a medical
procedure where your heart now lives
outside your body
i can there's a bit of me that kind of i
wish i'd done it sooner and then there's
another there's another bit of me that
goes
i wasn't ready for it sooner i'm ready
for it now
interesting my friend said that to me
he's just had a baby and he said i just
wish i'd done it sooner i'm thinking
really
but it got you to to there it's like
it's it's there's a great chinese
expression a great old proverb the best
time to plant a tree is 20 years ago the
second best time is now
pretty wise those chinese guys they know
what they're talking about
going back to you know your university
time because i remember because just
kind of going through in chronological
order i remember i was reading about how
you you know you you leave the nurse you
go and get you know you go and get uh
you go to cambridge which i thought was
amazing considering you're you know you
were an undiagnosed dyslexic i was
diagnosed
uh at the time you were undiagnosed yeah
i got diagnosed at college but i only
got diagnosed as dyslexic to get a free
laptop
i mean that was like i didn't really
particularly care didn't make any odds
you just get long longer to sit your
exams
but it was um yeah it's a it was not it
was nice i mean i think i wouldn't
recommend it to young people because i
think it's um
cambridge is still now very
anachronistic it's like going to college
in the 1950s
it's like a time machine it's like it's
just it's very old school and i mean
maybe it's changed a bit but i don't
think it's changed much like living in a
church yeah and it's cloistered in every
sense
yeah so it's
you know it is what it is but there's
you know it's also what are you going
there for
i think i went there for
in an unthinking way sort of it was a
away from something i think i'd
remembered at a very deep level not
being able to read when i was a kid and
kind of being in the special ed class
and then wanting desperately to prove
myself
and so you kind of get there and get
your degree and go right well i never
have to worry about that again
which is the dumbest thing in the world
i mean you know everyone with any kind
of education has educated themselves
because
really what do you remember from college
years ago yeah like it's whatever you're
reading now
and fast forward a few years you get
your degree you uh get a job at shell as
a marketing exec again unthinking
absolutely unthinking like it just it
wasn't like it was like a binary thing
of like going i didn't make a choice
when i was 16 to stay on at school that
was just like the sensible thing
what's everyone doing we're all staying
at school okay we're all going to go to
university then at 18. okay right what's
the best one okay we'll try and get to
the best one if you can't get into that
one get into the second best one if not
you know so you it's like a conveyor
belt and then after university was right
everyone's getting jobs okay i guess
i'll get a job but it's amazing how
little thought i put into my life
amazing really and when you consider
that i do something that is considered
to be uh you know very creative you know
write jokes and tell jokes for a living
and you go oh it was a lack of
imagination that kind of [ __ ] me
and and it [ __ ] you right tell me how
what were the symptoms of being [ __ ]
by that well i think it was the the it
was uh again sadness not depression but
in my mid-20s just thinking
is this it is this all there is
it felt like it was a trudge i didn't
have any purpose i was um
working to live not living to work and i
think
it's not not everyone's going to get
that not everyone gets that break and
i'm very aware that it's not like
come on dummies get a job that you love
and get up and you're excited about
every day it's like it's not easy for
everyone it takes an awful lot of work
to find out what that thing is that's
going to make your heart sing and then
you know you find something you love
doing and you never work again
it's not an easy thing but if you can
it's worth betting your life on it
you write about that in the book the two
adventures we all have in our lives
which is finding your purpose and
obviously going in the pursuit of it
what sounds like yours happened
crazy early
like
kicked out of school dropped out of
college and then
went right up starting the company like
that seems
and then you'd left the company by the
time you were 27 you were you were
almost on to midlife crisis i think at
27. that's true which is
it's it's completely true that's great
though i mean it means you get to die 50
and you've done everything exactly yeah
so what was what was the
what was that because do you see i mean
i sort of talk about a quarter life
crisis
of being finding your purpose and
cutting the apron strings and and that's
about i think it's about responsibility
it's about going oh i'm in charge of
this i can't blame anyone else this is
all me this is all my fault which should
be an empowering phrase but sounds
terrible but it's all my fault the idea
that right i'm i'm in charge
and i think it's often that thing of
like the expectation of parents or
whatever it is the the idea that you're
living your life
vicariously through someone else or
someone's living vicariously through you
rather
it's like
a jk rowling said this brilliant thing
about where do you draw the line
where do you draw the line on
taking responsibility for your life
because if a 16 year old kid says to me
yeah i'm kind of [ __ ] up but my
parents are dicks
you go oh that sounds fair enough
yeah okay but if a 40 year old says the
same thing you go
[ __ ] please come on yeah you're
40. where do you draw the line the
answer is
somewhere
somewhere you draw the line
and there'll be 16 year olds listening
to this going yeah i'm not blaming
anyone for any anything i'm just i'm
i'm doing this myself where did you draw
the line i think i was about 25. you
think 25 is where you're going to no no
that's why i don't okay for you it's
different for everyone okay it's gonna
be it's your road to damascus it's your
oh this is my one life i mean i think my
loss of religious faith was a very
important part of my
um same life i think it was a huge thing
of going religious faith faith for me
was the ultimate in procrastination it
was about the next life yeah and it was
also there's potentially a puppet master
and a judge
so i've just got to play to this bible
potentially or you know what when i was
the same i lost my religious faith in
christianity when i was 18. right i was
a bit late to the party i was about me
you know 24 25 something right
and it's it's um and i don't view it i
don't view atheism as like
this isn't going to be
um christopher hitchens and dawkins
you know it's not like it's not like a
dry
intellectual
aesthetic it's like it's a rush of blood
to the head it's like i've got one
[ __ ] life and this is it and we're in
it right now and there isn't a second to
waste yeah let's do this what are we
doing what am i doing what's exciting
what's fun what's yeah and and kind of
stand or fall it doesn't matter yeah
when i realized that i was an atheist
after trying to convince my brothers of
a jesus and a god and then really
realizing i was an atheist i spent two
years absolutely obsessed with atheism
so dawkins
i watched every video every book you
could read and then i was an antagonist
to religious people because it's almost
like i was trying to steal at the center
yeah it was still and they don't lose it
overnight so it's still yeah it's like
it's like people that are you know
people with you know oh well i live as a
um uh you know a hippie commune with no
belongings you're still putting money at
the center yeah exactly you're kind of
still the focus of that religious thing
of going well i've lost my religious
belief so now atheism is my new religion
exactly it's like an addict never really
gets over an addiction they just get
addicted to something new yeah and i
think that's why i think purpose is the
thing
and i think purpose as well
for someone who's had a religious
upbringing to go right well i'm going to
what's the new thing what are the new
rules for me
what are the rules for what's my
morality what's my life going to be like
so that's it's very exciting i mean it
really feels like it's a
i would encourage people to kind of
think about it and for me it was just
the basics i don't know how you lost
yours my mind was like so basic it was
exactly the same i read i read how you
lost yours and it was i it was exactly
the same if i'm right about this
then all those it's not yeah it's good
news for me and the other christian boys
but it's very bad news for ishmael yeah
yeah
tarek it's bad news for you yeah so you
went somewhere i went to jerusalem yeah
i went to jerusalem and i had to look
around and you go
oh this is some [ __ ] this is disney
i mean jerusalem's one of the most
beautiful cities in the world i would
encourage anyone to go there it's
wonderful and i love israel but
you go there and you go this is 900
years old not 2000 years old
please this is let's stop kidding
ourselves this is not none of this
happened this is disneyland
um and i think there's a stage of
throwing the baby out with the bath
water
and then you read more when i don't know
if you've kind of done this but you read
about the myth and what it is
and what it you know the story of christ
is interesting it's an interesting story
but the story the the
the the myth of it is interesting not
the factual character
i couldn't care less um but that thing
of like what remains when everything is
burnt away that's what i get from that
story
okay so if you burn everything else away
what's essential you what's the thing
that's left when there's nothing
that's interesting you go through trials
in life you go through you know hard
times and what remains
and when you lost your faith on that
point did you were you kind of
destabilized
by it yeah yes unanchored almost you
know yeah yeah i didn't leave my job to
be
rich and famous on tv
i left my job
for i don't yeah
yo ho ho a pirate's life for me we're
doing comedy i'm doing a gig above a pub
someone gave me 20 pounds cash in hand
that was i mean it was crazy i'd had
like a good
job but it's that thing where you go the
good is the enemy of the best
how much to not live your life
how much to not follow your dreams how
much do i have to give you across a
table
no i'm saying this to you now right
you're you're a wealthy man you're an
investor or whatever so it's going to be
a high figure but for most people
in their mid-20s they've just left
college or early 20s they've left
college and you go
i give you 35 grand to compromise on
everything and always be tired and just
work to my time and people go okay
that's the the thing of like working for
someone else is
i think
that that's the big shift right so the
the my stand-up is a metaphor in the
book i'm not trying to get people to
become stand-ups frankly i don't need
the [ __ ] competition
but the idea of going going and doing
your thing even if it's less successful
but doing your thing being your boss
being your ceo
great
that i'm all about that when people tell
me they've started a little business or
done a little thing you just go yeah
[ __ ] boss because you you get like
serial uh entrepreneurs because they do
it once and go yeah i'm not working for
anyone
i'm not let's challenge this
so
when i started my business i had many
many bosses because i had lots of
clients so i've got people that can call
me at 3m and just give me [ __ ]
and i think even as you know when i and
then i had investors as well and they
can call me and give me [ __ ] yeah but we
listen
bob dylan got to this before we ever did
we all have someone to serve
right that's just the nature of life
right so i listen i work for myself and
i'm [ __ ] boss and making huge money
i've got an audience to serve every
night i've got 2 000 people that need to
laugh for two hours
three times a minute and that's my boss
right so i've got to lean into i've got
to make sure that they're happy or none
of this can happen
so we all have people to serve of course
that's that's part of life you have but
you find out you do it on your terms in
your way
great
i don't mind the call at 3am i don't
mind the audience wanting more i don't
mind you know that's great of the travel
anything that's all fine because i have
the true north of a of a purpose
you know and then it's it's the other
thing on life where you kind of go
i write in the book quite a lot about
money
about the idea of like what is it
what's going on there because it's such
a powerful thing we spend so much of our
lives we give up so much for these
tokens and it's that classic line you
know to buy [ __ ]
we don't need to impress people we don't
like
it's like
the the who was it the it's byron has
the quote money is a magic lamp
you have to know what to wish for you
have to know what you want
otherwise what are you doing
i mean we're sort of in the city of
london now there's people working in the
city that are just like they're making
huge money and they're they're buying
the rolex but what for
quick one um when jimmy got here off
camera before we started chatting he uh
he walked up and he saw the fuel bottle
on the table and i went to explain to
him what he was and he goes oh you don't
need to tell me i drank you all the time
and he went on to explain that he has
fuel before he goes up on stage because
it's nutritionally complete it gives him
all the vitamins and minerals and energy
that he needs before he goes up on stage
um and that's exactly why i have you and
that's the beauty of having a podcast
sponsor that you so deeply believe in
and one that has genuinely transformed
your life i've just landed back from
indonesia i am all go because my entire
schedule because i've been away for
fraud weeks has been condensed into the
month of november
and i am running right now at a
tremendous pace to get everything in my
schedule ticked off huel is there to
make sure that my health and my
nutrition is ticked off at the same time
as my professional ambitions that's the
role it's always played in my life
to zoom me right in on that moment then
you're working at shell as a marketing
executive
there's a day is it a moment is it a
comment where you think [ __ ] this and
then to go from there
to comedian yeah it doesn't make any
sense
to an external one it doesn't i
okay so i had a boss there a guy called
mike hall who i'm recently kind of got
back in touch with a little bit
so i was i was working for shell i
initially worked for an advertising
agency he's the one you call an [ __ ]
in your book no i'm tricky
but that was good uh so he's he's that's
a typo um
the uh so i was working for an
advertising company and then i figured
out okay advertising this is this is
[ __ ] who are these people calling me
asking me for [ __ ] are marketing
managers right get into marketing so got
a job with shell so i'm working for
shell and then i kind of figured out
look i'm not happy here i was kind of
low energy i was not the funny guy in
the office i was just like oh this is
fine this is [ __ ] we're all working
here for shareholder value i could give
a [ __ ]
and
uh i
i went okay what's a cooler job what's a
better version of this so i went and did
like the mckinsey boston consulting
interviews so i was like i said to my
boss that's a nice guy marcus
mike i said look i'm gonna
i'm gonna go and try and get a job one
of these things and he sat me down in
his office and just went
no
i can't see it i can't see it
just she's just gonna have the same
problem somewhere else
i just don't see it
and that was kind of
enough it was enough that he saw me
as like a funny nice guy i just went
yeah this isn't for you you're in the
wrong stream
you know so the ladder
the analogy of the the ladder that
you've climbed is leaning against the
wrong wall
and there's no finer
like like ripping up your cv
metaphorically going i never need this
again
no one needs to know how i did in my
house ever again no one gives a [ __ ]
about my degree i mean maybe some of
this stuff will come in handy on qi 10
years later but otherwise who cares and
you're just off
doing your thing
and it's you know none of that was
wasted i mean an education is a
incredible thing what a gift to have
um but it just felt like it was it was
kind of freedom and they they did a
little voluntary redundancy thing which
was meant to get rid of the dead wood it
was meant to get rid of people at you
know 55 60 and just get them out the
door so more people could come in and i
was on the management graduate scheme
thing blue chip thing i just went yeah
can i what would i get if i left they
went five grand and i went i'm out
[ __ ] great not only am i leaving
they're giving my money to leave
and i was it's weird i had like a
reputation when i started doing comedy
of being
um
the hardest working comic because i went
out 300 nights a year every year the
first five years just like was like just
on it i was so feckless at work
it's a really good indication of if
you're doing the right thing if like i
used to put in a meeting at 11 a.m on a
friday and another meeting in at 2 a.m
so that i could go to a movie in
leicester square and be back and just go
oh yeah nothing happened
just like a lazy [ __ ]
isn't that insane i was exactly the same
i my attendance in school was 30 40 but
then and in fact it wasn't in my
business class i was 100 my business
class and then when i left school as
this lazy kid that was going to fail
yeah i outworked everybody at the thing
that i loved doing
business it's interesting right so it's
a really good
feedback loop of like for anyone
listening to this of going what do you
find easy what you know what's your edge
that's the other thing i talk about a
lot in the book your edge
what's your thing the thing that you do
better than anyone else you don't have
to be the best in the world by the way
you don't have to be better than anyone
else but what's the thing that you're
good at that you could get better at
that you could be better than you last
year
that's the key thing because take that
thing if you can find out what that is
for you
and then apply some hard work and time
that's your luck
be lucky i always say that like be lucky
but that that's what i mean by luck
luck and happiness being sort of the
same in german it's a lovely
uh sticky phrase like be lucky like if
you put that in you you're buying
lottery tickets every time right so that
hard work you put into the business it's
like lottery ticket lottery ticket
lottery ticket lottery ticket and hey
presto one of them hits because
you're there all the hours working all
the hours and you're working smart
you're working out the thing you're best
at you're kind of super focused on that
i want to talk to you about that point
about hard luck because that's been um
stigmatized in our society but before
that you said something which is f you
know find that thing within you that you
can be the best at the thing that you
enjoy etc etc when i when i say that to
people they always say to me
but steve how
how do i find the thing how do i find my
purpose is it just i sit down with
myself and make a list do i yeah i mean
i i literally went through uh there's
two books um zen and the art of making a
living i would recommend to people it's
still available and there's a book
called um what color is your parachute
they're quite corporate both even zen
and they are making living is quite
corporate but it's basically you write
essays about yourself and you you it's a
workbook it's like a big chunky workbook
i did both of them
and it kind of and for me i kind of then
slightly threw it away and went show
business baby but it's interesting of
like knowing yourself like who really
knows you
your friends probably know you ask them
ask them what they think it's it's an
interesting sort of process to kind of
go
like and you could be a ripe old age and
this would still apply like do you know
who you are how you're perceived and who
you really are what you feel like
um
because it's it's that thing where
you've got like those personality tests
online are not dumb to do you know that
um
no no there's a jordan peterson one
understanding myself like 100 questions
and it tells you things that's that's
worth i had a crack at that recently and
really enjoyed it like because you get
the results and go i agree with that
so that's surprising well you know it's
it's interesting it's almost like a um a
um
a horoscope like everyone likes their
horoscope right because
everyone's a little bit egotistical and
like i wonder what it says about me
and i think those personality tests kind
of can be very very useful for going how
are you going to find your edge what's
the thing you enjoy is it being with
people is it on your own are you
introverted extroverted that
myers-briggs thing might lead you in a
direction of going well i can't be i'm
not going to be a salesman i'm going to
be and these are jobs we're talking
about as opposed to
um
something beyond that like a purpose a
career an entrepreneurial spirit
um
people find that so i've done the mines
briggs i've done this i've done the
jordan pizza test and it's clear that my
passion is x but i'm in that job
unthinking as you describe it
and i've got a mortgage to pay i've got
you know bills well i mean that thing of
like i nearly fell into that trap
i was like the things you own end up
owning you
like there's nothing you can buy in the
mall that you give a [ __ ] about in five
years time
there's nothing
like like in the early phase of your
life and [ __ ] buy anything
because it's like it you know the things
you don't end up owning you like the
payments on a sports car nearly stopped
me going into comedy because you go well
what ties you down if i bought a house
in you know the 90s when i was you know
working michelle it would have been a
great investment and i never would have
left
because you're paying that mortgage
you're doing that thing
what do you need you know what do what
do you need the money for what are you
using the money for you know when you
take away the commute and you take away
the um the lunch that you're buying and
the night out the weekend and a couple
of drinks to you know because you need
some fun it's it's it's amazing how
little when i first year in comedy i
made literally no money i mean literally
nothing first money i got was 80 pounds
in cash for going to driving five hours
to plymouth and back but i had a little
bit
saved i had this like five grand from
shell and i was living at my mum's
uh initially so it was like it's fine i
had enough
you know that amazing story about um
kurt vonnegut and uh joseph heller
they're a party in new york
and the party's [ __ ] incredible right
so it's in the hamptons right so the
guys he's married to a supermodel he's
got warhols he's got picassos the house
is unbelievable like the wolf of wall
street party hats they're incredible
amazing party everyone's there and kurt
vonnegut
incredible writer says to joseph heller
this guy made more money one day last
week than you made out of catch 22.
like loves him and joseph fella goes
yeah but i got something he'll never
have
enough
what's enough
well it's enough for you what's what's
enough what's the there's two things
going on right there's there's safety
and security right there's uh our
caveman
thing of like going right well i need we
need to be secure that's about a bear
not attacking right we feel pretty
secure in our worlds right and then
scarcity is about it's another caveman
thing of like going okay so we need to
collect some stuff because winter is
coming so we need some we need some coin
we need a little bit of gold to take
care of us
how much is
enough i mean there's going to be a
trillion there next five years is going
to be someone's going to be a
trillionaire it's going to be in the
news you know why because a billion
wasn't enough
and the millionaires are billionaires
trillionaires
but they're working for money the money
is the is the important thing it's the
that's what that's the whole center of
their being
it's interesting because as i reflect on
my childhood i was clearly the one of
the big drivers for my success was
insecurity
broke family black kid in an all-white
school
um
parents were never in the house i'm
going to school every day with [ __ ]
stained trousers and stained t-shirts
and no money so like this this deep
insecurity must have been like sort of
burnt into me that like
if you get money steve then
you won't feel ashamed anymore it's
interesting i think it's a really
interesting point because
as someone that lost their faith
um i think fame and fortune are the
secular heaven
like we get rich and famous and
everything's okay yeah there's no
problems when you're rich and famous
that's what i thought everything's fine
well of course because it is like a if
you think about like legacy now
becomes
the afterlife yeah and fame and fortune
become
uh
the recognition of people that we don't
know becomes
a type of heaven
so i think that's a it's a perfectly
rational thing
to to you know are you moving towards
something or away from something well in
an ideal world it's kind of a mix of the
two and at what stage do you personally
and i think probably if i was i'm not a
psychotherapist but i would say you need
to build some ritual around it and i'm
sure you did when you sold your company
or left but build some ritual have a
trip do something shamanic and go
we did it we're okay we have enough
yeah and now focus on towards something
yeah but that's like that part of your
life is kind of over now right it's like
the the
what was that thing for you what was
that
trying to trying to escape pain and get
to a point of i guess freedom and
freedom is a very psychological thing
it's the freedom from shame freedom from
not being able to freedom from having to
do things you don't want to do and i
think really freedom from shame i think
that's probably the very heart of it oh
that's
i think that's what it is it's very deep
man because it's yeah it's that thing
where you go
i feel
um
empathetic towards the younger you
that's like a tough thing to have to go
through
but you go
kind of great
it's kind of great look at what look at
how far
you got
on away from yeah without even the
towards without even the amazing kind of
you know and it's it's like well what
next that's a it's a sad story but then
you you you look at people that got
given everything and have done nothing
because
they had no sense of purpose they had no
fire under them they had no
i think um
yeah it's it's
it's kind of an inspiring
story but then it's you know there's no
i suppose it's like what's going to
motivate you next what's going to be the
thing that you go
you know what do i want to do and this
is exactly it so you think about how
important purpose is for people to feel
stabilized and fulfilled et cetera as
we've talked about earlier and then you
think about these people that are
they're striving for a million a billion
a trillion well think about what a
mid-life crisis is right so i talk a lot
about midlife crisis in the book and you
go well midlife crisis is someone that's
found their purpose and they've done
their thing and then they've gone is
this it
yeah is this it and then they want
something like excitement
so what do they buy sports car is it
exciting i don't [ __ ] know i mean
maybe i mean if you're super into cars i
guess it's good but like they're on it's
all advertising speaks to this right i
know i'm right because all advertising
ever is about it's no longer about the
functionality of the product it's about
the well what
what what do you want you want you want
to feel like uh self-esteem like
self-esteem great rolls royce you want
excitement we've got ferraris for you um
you wanna get your dicks out we've got a
porsche whatever the thing is
the you know you've got
that that kind of there's a different
one and they're playing on different
emotions
and i think being aware of i mean i come
back to it all the time what do you want
is the fundamental question
like in any scenario when you sit down
to eat what do you want
what do you want from life
what do you want what's what's the thing
that you want and often it's it's often
asking that question multiple times
because the first answer tends to be
[ __ ] well
i think wishing wells work
right but they don't work when you think
they work
it's nothing there's no magic the magic
is if there is any knowing what to wish
for knowing what that thing is someone
says i want a million pounds you go you
don't know what you [ __ ] want you
want tokens for things that you might
want in the future
what do you want
what are you doing what are you trying
to be who who are you trying to become i
ask people young people specifically
this question and they will say things
that are all about external validation
so i want to be
like you know the one variation of
famous that you know basically public
speaker and you say why do you want to
be a public speaker and really when you
get to the crux of it what they actually
want to be is they want the admiration
that they think public speakers get
because
you know their dad didn't talk to them
or something yeah but i could see that
the idea of going i think a lot of that
is like
that tribal thing of going on and be
recognized i'm in a very privileged
position in that i'm famous and i would
argue
that's the norm
that's the norm for the longest time in
human history that everyone knew
everyone we used to live in much for
like
10 000 years you know what longer
the longest time we were in tribes
between 60 and 100 people everyone knew
everyone a stranger was a weird thing
and now we see strangers all the time
and we act like it's normal but it ain't
and so that desire to belong to be
famous what is was ever thus it's always
been that way
there was a there's a you know it was in
ancient rome people wanted to be famous
and wanted to be adored and wanted to be
that's like a it's valid and
and you know how do you deal with that
how do you
how do you get that thing and if if it
helps them strive
i think like i make a real distinction
between jealousy and envy
in
in the book and i talk about jealousy
being bad i don't want you to have that
i don't want you to have that i don't
necessarily want it but i don't want you
to have it [ __ ] that guy he shouldn't
have that why do you get given that
that's some [ __ ]
envy's really good
envy is like it's what you want it's
like motivation it's like oh that guy's
got an electric scooter that looks
really cool i'm gonna get one of those
great you know what you tells you what
you want it tells you what the what's
the thing that you're attracted to so i
think it's like it can be a real force
for good
so that thing of like when you were a
kid and you're looking at the other kids
and they're suited and booted and clean
and tidy going to school and their
parents are there and you go right i'm
building that for me
i i investigated this particular topic
in my in my book at great length but i
want to ask you the question as if i
don't know the answer because i want to
get your take on it um i agree with
everything you said and i i als
especially this point about knowing that
you're enough now
um
in my book i got to a point in chapter
18 where i'm like how do i know that i'm
enough right now but also
get the purpose and fulfillment that
comes from ambition and striving for
moral
and it felt like
a contradiction like i am enough i have
everything i need yeah i think we're
talking about here we're talking about
gratitude
it's that thing of life you're grateful
for what you've got you're grateful for
what you've got just the solid state if
you lose everything tomorrow you've got
your health right and there's people out
there that don't
and you've got friends around you
great you you know that gratitude can't
be stifling you've i mean they're like
practicing gratitude i mean they've done
all the statistical studies on it it
makes such a difference to your life to
be grateful for what you have
and to go right this is [ __ ] amazing
like i you know the older you get the
more your friends die the more you go
[ __ ] he never got to see this never got
to enjoy that thing never got to
sad i had a friend pass away recently
and you you just
you become aware of your mortality and
you're so grateful to be here and to be
in this game and to be
around
but that gratitude can't stop you from
going but i also want to go further and
farther and
i think the great thing about being a
comic is
we're brilliant with failure
we made friends with failure a long time
ago we've died many times on stage i've
written more jokes that don't work than
you
so many more
you may not have written any jokes that
don't work i've written thousands of
them but that thing of like that
feedback loop of failure is so
it's it's such a great life lesson to
learn because you go well look i can
fail all the time and i'll fail and i
fail and i fail and i'll eventually i'll
fail so many times i run out of ways to
fail and then i'll we'll call that
success
and you kind of you build and build and
you kind of go well what's the next
thing i'm going to do i'm very lucky
because i have a job which is it's a
task without end and that's where i
think happiness lies in those tasks
without end where you go right i'm going
to
spend my time trying to be a better
comic
i'm going to try and write in a
different style i'm going to try and be
i'm going to try and be a goat i'm going
to try and be on the mount rushmore of
comedy now i know that probably won't
happen
but i've got a [ __ ] lottery ticket
and i'm allowed to try and do it and
that feels like an incredibly that feels
like a life's journey
i don't know if that did that answer the
question i don't know if it did perfect
yeah but then the the the question was
about
no you did because you were famous
beyond you refrained my point which was
um about knowing you're enough you're
afraid to gratitude and when and
gratitude and ambition can co-exist yes
it's a tricky one though isn't it
because sometimes you feel like am i
being ungrateful by wanting more yeah
yeah and also and how much of a kind of
you're kind of going i've already got a
lot of stuff do i need any more stuff do
i need any more but it's i guess it's
not about
things or people it's about how we spend
our days ultimately so it's not about
like there isn't a god no one's keeping
score there's no one from above who's
going to go at the end of your life okay
let's take a look at the stats
and in my head i kind of wish there was
someone going you did that many so
what's happiness
right i've got a couple of theories on
happiness
i think flow states are where happiness
lives what's a flow state so i know
if you get into a state where you lose
track of time that's a pretty good
indicator
a lot of people get it with
sports okay so you you doing something
that you so enjoy you're so engaged in
this activity you forget even where you
are you might get it playing video games
i get it on stage what i'm just in this
moment and i enjoy i'm totally engaged
and i'm i'm in the flow you see
musicians
kind of embody it on stage
spend as much time in a flow state
as you can in life
if that can become your job then
tremendous that is
that's success
everything else is
who cares but that thing is like that's
amazing so what's your flow state what's
the state what's the thing you do where
you go this is this is my [ __ ]
what is it
for me yeah
a lot of things come to mind one of them
is um i've got this show that's touring
at the moment it's in the london
palladium in february um and i was as
you were saying that i was imagining
sitting in the chair on stage with with
my choir and it that feels like my flow
state feels like i'm just on my own
just and you're floating you'll try and
hold on to that moment yeah you'll try
and it's like quicksilver because it's
like the time will just float by yeah
and you know you'll be there and there's
kind of a high before the high even
thinking about it but that thing of
going that's next february
that won't do you're going to need that
once a week you're going to need that
once a day like more of that like
leaning into that edge of going that's
if that's where i'm happy
that's where you should be
this is lovely actually i think
i think kind of there's it's uh i think
the reason sort of panel shows are so
popular on tv
is because this is missing from our
culture like this is how we should end
every day
the reason podcasts are blowing up is
because people desperately want to be
in a conversation and there's something
very intimate about podcast there's
something about
the long form and listening that's
really
when you don't do that
yeah you can't do the monsoon there's no
eye contact my other theory on happiness
is its expectations exceeded oh yeah
because
listen birthdays are [ __ ] right
new year's eve [ __ ] waste of time
amateur drinkers i've never had a good
new year's eve never new year's eve is
[ __ ] all and why because the expectation
is this is gonna be the best night ever
again it's gonna be huge everyone's
gonna be there even if everyone is there
and it is a really good night you go but
i thought it was going to be amazing and
it was just
really good
and then sometimes on a [ __ ] tuesday
someone goes
i just want i bumped into the guy and
then we went to a thing and then we
ended up at a at a [ __ ] great time
it's the
it's that thing of like tricking
yourself into kind of just lower your
expectations maybe a little bit less
time looking at what everyone else is
doing on holiday on instagram is pretty
healthy and looking around trying
enjoying the little simple pleasures and
oh we ordered in and the food was
[ __ ] amazing and it arrived half
great does that link to your point about
comparison being the thief of joy of
course yeah compare and despair
everyone's having a better time often
check
instagram now we're going to feel like
dummies for sitting here having a really
interesting conversation oh [ __ ] we
should be [ __ ] water skiing in the
amazon yeah we're dummies
but it's being where you're at right so
it's
and that's raising our expectations of
how our lives should be going when i see
timmy doing his jet skiing and but it's
it's oh the places you won't go
oh the things you won't do to be where
you are
there's a million people you're not
because you you did this and you didn't
do that
now you could have gone down another
road maybe you could have been a great
sportsman maybe you could have been a
great
academic but you didn't go down that
road you went down this road
and enjoying that and being where you're
at is kind of it's kind of important you
know once you commit to something
it's like
you you know you're it's fine but you
can't like all these different i think
it's it's overwhelming at the moment
what's going on in in social media
because it just feels like you're
constantly bombarded by
options and easy lives
you know the latest kind of iteration of
the fame heaven myth is reality starts
so that there's a big difference between
again another conflation
but being a celebrity and being famous
i'm famous
but i'm not celebrity i'm famous for
something that i do
but celebrities just
themselves
it's the queen or a kardashian they're
just themselves and the money rolls in
and it's tremendous
it's just it's a [ __ ] lottery win
hard work very pivotal to your um
you getting here today by the sounds of
it especially in those early years as a
comedian after leaving shell
what role does hard work play in our
society um it's very in in becoming a
successful individual at whatever
pursuit or whatever passion you're
pursuing there's a there's probably a
counter narrative that i think has
emerged in our country maybe because of
social media has allowed people to kind
of converge behind that and relinquish
responsibility of their situations by
calling hard referring to hard work as
being a really really sort of toxic
thing and i've i felt that more recently
i didn't see it when i was younger i
mean let's let's you know what let's
have a you gambling man uh not it
depends i mean in life not in the casino
yeah let's let's put a bet on that let's
see how that works out for them
i just don't think that's gonna bring
them happiness
which part the hard work is toxic
okay
okay don't do don't do hard work then
good luck dummy
it's just not gonna work for you that's
not gonna pay out because what's the
metric of our society it's results right
and i don't care how there's two great
myths in our society right there's one
myth is talent
and
ideas and there's another myth which is
hard work they're both [ __ ]
total [ __ ] [ __ ] because the the
ideas are cheaper than table salt right
there's there's everyone's got ideas
i've got an idea for an app it's the
uber for
fill in the thing here it's yeah great
sure sure it's every idea is about
implementation
every um sports is a good analogy right
so michael jordan greatest of all time
right there's no
debate he's the greatest how much did he
work [ __ ] more than anyone else how
much natural talent did he have more
than anyone else
what if he hadn't worked
you never heard of him
he never would have made the team let
alone being the greatest but wouldn't
have even made the team if he hadn't
trained it's a good analogy for life of
going look whatever talent you have if
you don't do the work as well it's it's
it's just a waste of potential so i
think it's it's the absolute fundamental
now
hard work and drudgery are not the same
thing right like there's a there's a
working smart and working hard and
there's a difference between the two
like if you're if you're working at
something and it's like hard work alone
won't do anything you know it's about
what stream you're in
and i suppose the extreme example would
be if you're collecting
um
you know recyclable metals on a favela
dump in south america work as hard as
you want
nothing's ever gonna you're never gonna
get to that level so you work hard if
you must and you work smart if you can
if you can't you know if anyone
listening to this is already in a
privileged position
in the
you know odds are western world doing
okay
have a digital phone that's
you're doing better than a third of the
world before you even start
you know most people don't have running
water you know most people don't have a
flushing toilet the world's in a [ __ ]
terrifying state so it's that thing of
going well work as smart as you can work
at the thing that you're best at
i think school teaches us maybe the
wrong lesson school teaches us a lesson
about mediocrity and being all around us
and yet we live in a world that does not
reward all rounders
who gives a [ __ ] about all around us
if you if you get a d in physics
and you get an a in english
i say just go to english lessons
because we're going to get you up to a c
grade in physics i'll tell you what the
world doesn't need someone who's [ __ ] at
physics
still [ __ ] at physics with no natural so
find out what you've kind of got a
natural
you know that edge thing find out what
you have a natural ability for what's
the thing that you do best and again i
would remind people it's not the best in
the world just better than anything else
you do
lean into that like i'm all for
following your dreams if your dreams are
what you're best at
and the opinions of family and friends
don't count
and then it's it's a little bit i
suppose it's a bit tough love it's that
thing of going look look at what your
inner critic says okay and
it won't be wrong
look at what your inner critic says
about you walk back the cruelty
and you gotta okay that's the reality
that's the starting point i read that in
your book and i was in i was laying in
bed it was actually already a book i was
listening to and i and
you said the thing about your inner
critic which a lot of people obviously
don't want to admit is their inner
critic is usually right and i remember
sitting there thinking now that can't be
right let me check this and then i
started listening to my inner critic for
a couple of seconds and i thought no
that's right that's right that's right
but please expand on the idea of well
look
the idea of the inner critic is going
look i i went to a
fancy university right and i think
cambridge is where imposter syndrome was
built
there's a lot of imposter syndrome in
the world right you arrive at a new
workplace and you go jesus they must
have made a mistake and got the wrong cv
and given me the job and all right well
i'm at this new college or i'm i'm at
this new i'm starting this thing and i
don't know what i'm doing
that feeling of i'm not enough and i
don't know what i'm doing
is why you buy the
business management for dummies book and
[ __ ] read it the night before it's
what drives you to do the homework so i
got to cambridge and i thought i'm not
smart enough to be here and then i
worked my [ __ ] nuts off and it turned
out i was wrong and i was smart enough
to be there and i did really well
because i [ __ ] because i was
motivated by the i'm not good enough to
be here i need to work i need to work
hard you know you start in comedy and
you go oh my god i've
given up everything to be a comedian
i've got 20 minutes of jokes that work
i i'm gonna need thousands of jokes that
work and they all have to work
[ __ ]
you get to work
what's the motivation what's the thing
that wakes you up for in the morning and
you go i need to [ __ ] do this
i can't rely on just being hey i'm just
getting a wisecrack and you know asking
a comic to improvise an hour-long show
is like asking a magician to do real
magic
the work is done in the gym by the time
i get to the stage i know it's going to
be a good show i know i've tried these
jokes on other people i know we're a
lock
you know 10 20 of the evening is about
the fun that happens in that room the
messing around the audience that the
showing off the work that i've done in
the gym the muscle memory of not knowing
how to make people laugh great
but i'm going to arrive ready
there's something really interesting in
that when you're talking about the
reason why you succeeded at cambridge is
because you didn't feel like you were
smart enough to be there and etc etc etc
that also sounds a lot like what i
described when i said the reason why i
pursued money and trying you know tried
to be successful was because i felt
inadequate
in my in myself it and it became this
great motivator yeah and this there's
there's like a there's a there's a plus
to that and then there's this potential
danger in but are we being a bit like
you know that that thing of going
giving kids too much self-esteem giving
people not kids necessarily because this
is about life stage right what we're
talking about here isn't about when you
leave college and when you're young and
when you're doing something right
there'll be people listening to this in
their 40s that are going to start a
business and do something [ __ ]
exceptional with their lives there's
people in their 50s that are going to do
that it's people in their 60s i don't
believe there's like a knock-off point
people in their 70s you struck those
people
the delta variant dealt with n they're
gone man there's none left i'm sorry hey
the good news is the pensions crisis is
over
but that thing of like going well you're
gonna you know people people do
people do extraordinary things if they
if but they they put the work in
and and i think people lean into the
myth of like
that thing of like oh he's a genius
you read you know forbes magazine or
whatever about business people doing
incredibly well it's like well this
guy's a genius steve jobs thing is
though genius genius love bill gates is
genius and then you read about like
these these guys that are like finance
guys they wake up at five in the morning
and he only sleeps for three hours a
night and he does so much and he knows
everything about he works so hard
it's always both it's always both
and then plus time you need you know
that ten thousand thousand hours thing
isn't
isn't wrong it's just that's the minimum
what could you stand to do for ten
thousand hours that won't feel like
drudgery
what could you stand to do
now for the next 10 years of your life
that won't feel like oh this again
and if you're only motivated by the
paycheck it's like well
how hard could you work
quick one as many of you know i've been
trying to make my life a little bit more
sustainable as it relates to energy ever
since i sold my range over sport and
bought an electric bicycle and my energy
as a sponsor of this podcast one of the
brands that make that transition much
much easier they are at the forefront of
british renewable ecosmart technology
and their products are really really
changing the game if you're on youtube
you can see what i'm holding in my hand
this is called the eddie right it's the
uk's number one solar powered diverter
so what is a solar diverter it's a
device for people like you and me that
means you can divert your excess energy
back into your home rather than back
into the grid which will save you power
and money it's super user friendly and
easy to install and you can control it
using the my energy app on your phone to
find out more about this product and
more products like here that will help
you make that sustainable transition
head over to myenergy.com and um i
highly recommend you check out the eddie
it's um it's a real game changer for a
product and one that i'm going to be
installing in my home soon
paychecks you you talked about one of
the lessons you brought over from your
business career was um
branding
you you said one of the the
most important things you carried over
from your business career to stand up is
branding you sell your speciality
yeah i think that that thing like i mean
branding in a very loose sense it's that
thing of like knowing how you're
perceived so when you walk on stage if
you're like suited and booted and you
look as if you're hosting a tv show
how long is it going to be before some
dummy a tv channel goes
he should be hosting a tv show this guy
looks the part
like that thing of like that simple
thing of going this is a visual medium
i'm standing in front of people i don't
think it's not like people go oh you
know if you don't get them in the first
five minutes you're in trouble five
minutes you're having a laugh if you
don't get them in the first
on the before i've hit the mic they've
made a decision about me in a club
you know this guy oh this guy's [ __ ]
knows we can all relax this this guy
knows what he's doing take the wishing
well yeah and it's like that thing of
like you go
you know someone someone uh
faking confidence
is
exactly the same to the casual observer
so that thing of like what you're what
are you faking
fake being a good person to the casual
observer it's the same
being a good person to the casual
observer tax that seems like a good
segway yeah well i mean the tax things
really it's quite an interesting thing
when you get publicly shamed
uh that you can't you know you learn a
lesson you you don't i totally missed
that oh okay well i mean
what happened was there was a uh
the long story i suppose is
you have an accountant right your
accountant says how much tax do you want
to pay yeah there's a scheme and you go
yeah great is it legal yeah they go yeah
it's legal and you go
okay
and they go yeah you can pay as much as
you want or pay this or it's quite they
use terms like it's quite an aggressive
scheme and you go oh okay
but there's less tax and you get to keep
okay that's well that sounds good
and i suppose every anyone that's ever
bought an isa
has done a tax avoidance scheme
that's a government-backed tax avoidance
scheme so i was doing a bunch of those
and government enterprise initiative
things and trusts and quite complex
financial things so the money was
rolling in and it was just all going
through the accountants out to these
things
and
one day it all caught up so one day
i don't know how exactly i presume hmrc
leaked something but that's okay
uh and
it went from being on the cover of the
paper to going you know you've done an
aggressive attack scheme this is morally
wrong and i'd never thought of it as
being moral i'd never i just go on while
i pay as little as you can and whatever
i'm still kicking in a lot
and it was just like
i i had that feeling it was almost like
um suicide with a bungee rope you felt
like you were losing everything
and then it kind of snapped back and it
was okay but the sensation of what it
would be like to
be cancelled
i've had that that kind of you know not
ptsd i haven't been in a bomb blast but
you know you have that feeling of like
what that would be like
um
so and then the prime minister comes out
and he's at the g20 and he does a press
conference where he talks about nothing
other than your tax affairs and how
morally representable you are and he's
the guy that brings in austerity and
gave us brexit and you know scottish
independence and whatever
and you go oh [ __ ] i'm
this is gonna be
and then i'm doing a topical comedy show
that week
where we're talking about the most
talked about things
and i'm the most talked about thing
how did you actually feel in that moment
i was behind the scenes i had uh so the
news broke on a sunday i was i didn't
sleep for about maybe three days i mean
you know i didn't sleep you know there's
always an hour here or there but
i was having panic attacks uh and that
sensation of a panic attack if you
haven't had one
is you you you can't
get comfortable in your own skin you
can't sit you can't stand you can't eat
you can't drink you're just like
nothing feels right you're kind of
just off and i i took some i took like a
beta blocker on the first day
and then i had the meds i had like the
beta blockers and the valium and the
stuff i got like prescribed enough to
send me down a black hole
and then i didn't take anything i just
had them as a talisman of like okay i'll
have that but it was kind of panic
attacks and waves of that and uh
guilt and shame
and
you know hard lessons
because you find out who your friends
are
so
a couple of people that i was pretty
close to
were
gleeful
were well that guy's been brought down a
peg or two
like
so that's a hard thing it's a hard thing
to learn and then some other people
stepped up to the plate
you know and you go wow that's
i'm not really interested in fair
weather friends like everyone comes to a
showbiz party of course they [ __ ] do
the show is party baby um but the people
that call you when you're at your lowest
and go
fine
i love you you're you're not the worst
thing you've ever done
you go great
and on that point you you talk
openly about how you've had
depressive bouts
yeah i mean i i spoke about it in the
book because i think it's a um
again i wanted to kind of deliver on
listen if i hadn't talked about the tax
thing in the book i think readers would
have felt shortchanged
very much like hmrc did
but again the depression and anxiety i
suffer more with anxiety than depression
and i try and see in a very positive way
i try and be as positive as i can in
life and go so if i have an anxiety
attack you go well that's sort of the
flip side of creativity right so if you
have a mind that's whirring all the time
you know sometimes it's going to wake
you up at five in the morning with a
panic attack and that's all right you
know i can white knuckle that i'm not
i'm lucky that mine aren't that severe
it's not like i'm
better and braver than other people with
mental health problems that need to
medicate i'm just lucky that it's not as
bad for me
but i'm aware of it and i think talking
about it does help because all we have
is talking therapy
so if that talking therapy is me someone
listening to my book and going oh he
seems all right and he's he deals with
this and he's going through it and i
know that i'm not alone in this
because the first time you have a panic
attack it's [ __ ] terrifying because
you think
is this my forever now
because it's all you can feel and it's
overwhelming and you go well is this it
is the first time you get depressed
the first time like a real depression
hits you it's like oh wow this is a
this
is awful when was the first time
um the first one was probably early
twenty early twenties like after college
like uh uh
a black mood that just wouldn't shift
and it was
yeah
uh yeah that's pretty it was pretty
scary
and then i had i had one in australia a
couple of years ago in 2018
where i and i could kind of see what it
was like there's a bit of your mind
that's like always
you know aware and it was like i
traveled that i'd done like 160 flights
that year and it was i did australia
twice in a month and it's i was so broke
and i was so stripped of serotonin and i
took a valium to sleep on the plane and
that strips more serotonin and i was
just like it's the inability to feel joy
um so i don't know if you've had anyone
die in your life but sometimes someone
on their deathbed you make them their
favorite meal
you get the food from the specialty but
i remember going to see a friend who was
dying and we bought him scotch eggs from
fortnum and mason it's his favorite
thing
and he looked at him and he was grateful
but he couldn't eat them because he just
didn't have an appetite and when you're
depressed it's the appetite for life
is just gone
it's just you haven't got it
um
but it's this too shall pass you know
the the that thing of going well you can
just
you know i can white knuckle it and just
kind of get through that and other
people can medicate for a couple of
weeks and they're sort of okay
and do you think these things are
it's an interesting question to ask and
probably quite naive but do you think
these things are
a symptom of the way we live our lives
panic attacks
depression or do you think they are
part of the innate human experience
regardless of the way that we live our
lives i think it's a it's a great
question
i think uh i think depression is a part
of life
i think it's you know probably people
have always had that and i think there
is a um
there's a there's a benefit to these
things
there's a um
it's not only negative you know
melancholy can be a very beautiful thing
sometimes it's very appropriate to be
down you know if you're grieving someone
that's you know you talk about being
depressed when someone dies you you it's
grief it's a different sort of thing
that's uh of course it's it's uh it's
normal i think that thing about for me
i think
you know the nurture thing is the thing
that we can change i'm i'm a great
believer that we could change and do
better
but
yeah maybe it's
maybe is a symptom of how we're living
our lives and we could do better
you know i'm sure if i was doing
um ayahuasca every weekend i'd have less
panic attacks
but
at the moment i don't feel kind of drawn
towards that world but i'm kind of aware
that that exists
i've kind of got some friends in that
world and i'm aware there's other i've
got a friend that was on antidepressants
for 30 years
and started doing ayahuasca and is now
off them now it's not even first hand
it's definitely not scientifically
relevant don't take medical advice from
me kids but it strikes me that there are
other ways there's other ways in that
there's ancient cultures that had this
[ __ ] locked down
you didn't lose your virginity until you
were 26
yeah very late and again i spoke about
that in the book because i think there
is a
perception in society that it is a race
and you need to do that early and you
need to be
you know [ __ ] with a weapons grade
dick because
everyone's watching pornhub and you know
whatever it's it's uh
i thought it was a nice thing to share
because i think some kid of 24 is going
to read that and go i might be all right
i might be normal you describe that as
being a fear i remember very distinctly
trying to have sex when i was 16 and
just being totally [ __ ] terrified
because i thought my penis was i thought
it was i mean i think i probably would
watch too much pawn or something at 16
or 17 but i was like this is not a penis
this is
tiny in comparison to that i think we
have to get our dicks all right
i think we have an ending for the show i
was like 15. and i and i totally bottled
it what was it was it fear was it i
think it was you know i think it's fear
you know there's a lot of other things
going on obviously it's like maybe a
religious faith 15 of that and maybe a
little bit
enmeshed is the term they use where
you're you know too close to one parent
and that maybe stops you from forming
bonds with uh with other women so very
close to my mother and that stops you
from kind of going out and having normal
relationships in some sense you know
there's a million different reasons it
kind of doesn't matter it's like you
everyone gets there
and the perception i think again in our
society and the reason to put it in the
book is because you go i'm not
embarrassed give a [ __ ]
like i very happily talk about it and
you go
don't get too caught up in the reasons
uh think about now think about what
matters i think that you know that
school of therapy the freudian analysis
that's all about why that happened and
give a [ __ ] what are we going to do
about it
i like cbt and nlp more because it's
more like yeah what are we going to do
though what are we doing now what are we
doing today
nlp neuro-linguistic programming yeah
peter jones was talking to me a lot
about this one when we were having our
breaks in dragon's den and
what role has nlp played in your life
what has it done for you and for those
that don't know including me what is it
um neuro-linguistic programming is like
i suppose it came out the
west coast human potential movement of
the 70s it's a sort of almost like a
belief structure
of for life
uh and it's been you i think it's been
used nefariously a fair bit you can find
some negative stuff on it online i
happened to when i was working for shell
there was a budget for training and
obviously i'm not working on an oil rig
i was like okay well i'll just
i'll i'll go on an nlp course like this
kind of
slightly hippie-ish thing for a big oil
corporation to send you on and
the idea of it is the map is not the
territory it's like the fundamental
questions in life are going look your
experience of the world is not the same
as everyone else's
and how you see things within the map
inside your mind is how the world is for
you
and you know so these premises of like
the quality of your communication is the
quality of your life
which made sense to me everything about
it i read this kind of i was taught by
this guy called in dermot and everything
i he said like for you know 20 days on
this course i just went i agree with all
of this
i i
it everything felt right to me about
that it felt like okay someone's given
this a lot of thought and we're all
standing on the shoulders of giants we
you know and this seems like a pretty
good way to
um to think about life
um so the idea that the map is not the
territory the idea that you go well you
imagine how things are you could imagine
it a different way it's very difficult
to change how you think about the world
very difficult
but it's so much easier than changing
the world the map is not the territory
so you imagine the world right yeah you
imagine um
london yeah and the size of london and
what it is
what you have in your head isn't the
real thing
it's your perception of it it's your
perception of how things are in this
room is not it's not the same as my
perception of how they are in this room
um
so it it's it's different for everyone
the
the idea and the analogy being there's a
map that's 2d and it tells you right
that's britain that's france
you have an idea of what britain looks
like from above
it's got [ __ ] all to do with reality
no one's ever seen it from that angle
so you you know those lines don't exist
those lines are man-made
the the borders aren't real and how does
that help you in in life
well i think it's the idea of going look
you can change the way that you think
about things so i was thinking about
things in i can do i can do these this
narrow bandwidth of things my belief
system the assumptions i'd made about
life were well you can get a job and you
can work for someone and after you get a
job and you work for 40 years you get a
pension and when you get the pay
i was on a conveyor belt sure
when suddenly i went
oh i could believe anything
i could believe that i could do anything
i could believe that i could be the guy
on the tv show
tell the jokes
and you can what you believe
dictates your life you'll you'll be the
barrier you'll be the thing that stops
you
no one else you know people spend a lot
of time worrying about other people
oh what if they don't help me what if
they don't you're going to be the thing
that holds you back
you said that the best goals are those
without like the destination
right the i mean listen it's the the the
listen this is a very self-help chat
right so we are legally obliged to say
at some point it's the journey not the
destination we have to say that but
getting there isn't half the fun it's
all the fun
so what's next for you
okay well i have plans i always have
plans i have quite grand plans if you if
you say now that you want to make a
billion dollars i'm gonna delete this
episode
uh i'm trying to get better at comedy
i've been sort of going about 20 years
and i'm trying to change up my style a
little bit so i do this is the inside
baseball people you can switch off now
if you're not interested in comedy so i
do one-liners everything's a fastball
right and i do sort of three a minute on
stage and i try and get people into a
state where they're
they can't breathe where they're
laughing so much whether
a joyful
experience where they can't remember
anything i said but they remember how i
made them feel and i made them feel so
happy that's what i want to do okay i'm
trying to change that a little bit i'm
trying to change it up so i'm doing i'm
trying to write routines between sort of
seven and 12 minutes long trying to
write longer pieces with a bit more to
them so i'm trying to sort of find a
it's been really interesting with the
book and with coming on podcasts like
this of like finding a different voice
so going i'm a public figure i've been
on tv for 20 years pretty famous i've
never spoken like this before right
so we've just done a couple of podcasts
recently where i'm chatting to people as
i am and you go okay so that's there's a
serious side to me and then there's a
funny side to me people are nuanced and
complicated and great and i'm trying to
bring a little bit of who i am to the
stage now i'm trying to
reveal a little bit more about me
and that's a very exciting
prospect and so writing a new show so
i'm sort of halfway through a tour and
i kind of pushed the [ __ ] button and
recorded a special that's going to come
out at christmas
and
i've written new stuff why just go out
and do new stuff why it's exciting
it's it's like the the trying new stuff
doing new things trying trying to get
people to a different state
so it's a little bit
for the for the adulation of it because
you kind of go well
i want it to be a better experience for
the audience
but also i want more applause breaks i
want it to be a um
a higher volume laugh you know there's a
there's a
it's difficult to describe but there's
like this there's a laugh that you got
everyone in the room laughed bang but
then it's gone and then get them again
bang and then and then it's gone you
want a rolling
laughter you want you know i want to get
better i want to get better i've seen
people that are better than me on stage
with worse material
with worse jokes you go so you want to
get better as a performer and you want
to get better as a writer and it feels
like this i feel like i'm at base camp
i've got the kit i've got the right gear
and i'm i'm on the mountain
but we haven't got anywhere near the
summit and that's for me tremendously
exciting as a guy in his late 40s to go
oh we're just starting most of the great
comics that i love did their best work
in their 50s
inside your book in the front cover
and this is my um last question for you
it says
that one of the things the book will
help
you understand
is the meaning of life
pretty profound
i'll do it in five words okay enjoying
the passage of time
that's it it's enjoying the passage of
time
it's it's
the chances of us being here now
are so small
the chances of us existing it's it's
almost you know if you look at the if
you look at the stats the it's not just
our parents had to get together at that
moment but their parent their parents
their parents going back a billion years
as we climbed out of the soup the
chances of this happening are
incalculable and yet we're here
and we have this shot and we're
breathing and we're healthy and we're
this is incredible
enjoying the passage of time is about
it's about all i got and it's enough
thank you um i i found your you know
your book incredibly
refreshing for so many reasons because
it was laced with humor but because it
was so inclusively written
as a self and so relatable absolutely i
kind of felt like it was low-hanging
fruit the self-help thing because you go
well eckhart tolle's amazing yeah he
does not know his way around a dick joke
and you know and and jordan peterson
great 21 rules for life but it's like
it's quite pitchy yeah yeah it's just a
tone you know so you go actually
sugaring the pill and going look there's
this great interesting world out there
and i think this is like a
i think this book is a gateway drug
i think this is marijuana this is like
some really mellow
weed and it'll lead you in a different
direction like maybe okay well i need to
read some more stuff by him or i need to
investigate that or that sounds
interesting and the honesty you start
the book with even confronting the fact
that there's a stigma to writing
self-help books it immediately builds
trust very early that you're not going
to [ __ ] me and you're not going to
try and be anybody you're not in this
book and so i as i as i listened into
the audiobook and the chapters passed
you'd establish this really high degree
of trust with me because
you kind of had pointed at the elephant
in the room so early it's it's
interesting that thing of like the the
experience you had as well about the
inner critic
where
you engaged with the book yeah to a to a
degree where you went is that true is
that it's a it's it's an interesting
thing to be able to give someone i
haven't met
something that is essentially very tough
love yeah i know it was and the other
thing that was even tougher love was at
one point you say that i am the person i
am when no one's watching and at that
exact moment as i'm in my boxing shorts
with the pot noodle like spilt on my
belly and it's like 2 a.m in the morning
i'm thinking this is who the [ __ ] i am
i like i swear i feel i feel like i sat
up in the bed it was like i like i love
that thing though of going like if
you're listening to this in the car yeah
and you just threw a beer can out
yeah that's who you are
that's not terrible you just have to be
okay with it it's a good it's i think
honesty is one of the great superpowers
of comedians because
everything's built on that level of like
people aren't going to get the joke if
it's not honest yeah yeah but it's it
that bedrock of like acceptance is a
great first step look you are where you
are it's not where you can end up
and you know i think i get the feeling a
lot of people listening to this podcast
are looking for something they're
looking for kind of a a steer
and it's it's you know there's gonna be
movement you're gonna you're going in
the right direction just the desire to
get there is enough to get you started
well thank you it's um i'm so incredibly
happy you wrote this book because it
also showed me someone i've watched on
tv since i was a child right i've been
around a long time
and uh so it's also surreal meeting you
because as i said you know you're one of
the people that i sat there in my house
in plymouth you know that [ __ ] whole
place that you described yeah um and i i
i watched you growing up and i knew one
side of you i knew the the quick jokes i
literally remember the sketch you did
where you said you come up on stage and
you say i'm gonna do as many [ __ ]
one-liners as i can and you just hammer
them all out and reading this book and
also meeting you today as exactly what
you've described as your kind of
ambition
i've come to learn a how unbelievably
[ __ ] smart you are i didn't actually
know you'd gone to cambridge until i
read about it um
be how um multifaceted you are as a sort
of philosophical thinker
and see your incredible ability to weave
that all together into
shine lights on really important truths
in society and that's why when you told
me that your ambition going forward is
to bring
a bit more
content we'll say and a little bit more
probably profound meaning and i don't
know
to your to your
comedy you know what it is i saw
chappelle the other week really yeah and
i shock people yeah and he disturbs
people yeah and what i need to do is
disturb people yeah
yeah i mean you have all the everything
it takes to do that because you really
are a genius in your own right so this
is you're way too kind thank you it's
been a
pleasure now i have to write a question
for them yes you have to write a
question so all of you write me a
question yes
what do we do first do i get the
question i'm going to ask you the
question first so all of our guests
leave a question in the diary okay as
they leave and they don't actually know
who they're leaving the question for
which is interesting
right we had
patrice evra who's a manchester united
football legend um
is this going to be about the offside
rule is this gonna catch me out it's not
okay in fact interestingly this is a
question which changed his life when his
his partner asked him this question one
day
and
it
disturbed troubled and caused a sense of
introspection that made him
really really consider this seriously
and that changed his life that was the
catalyst so when i said to him to write
a question i looked down at what he had
written and it was the question he
described on this podcast so listeners
of last week's episode we'll know we'll
know this question coming okay
because the question is
are you happy
yeah
it's a great question
yes
it is a really great question
it's really good it's beautiful yeah
it's beautiful and i think you know um
that thing i said earlier about like be
lucky i had a
friend's father when i was a kid i would
always say be lucky and i remember
thinking it was ridiculous because you
can't be lucky
but that you know from there
the german luck is uh happy
be happy
i think it's a it's a powerful thing to
aspire to
you know enjoying the passage of time is
my answer for the meaning of life but to
be happy
is
everything and i think you are
responsible for your happiness
you know uh objectivism and hang around
get given a hard time i think because i
think people have conflated pleasure and
happiness and they think those guys are
just hedonistic fools but you being
happy is better for the world
you know when you're on a plane and it's
going down and the oxygen masks come you
have to grab your mask first or you're
no good for anyone else
you being happy makes the people around
you happier better for your friends
better for your family better for the
world
it's a great question
weirdly my one of my my ex-girlfriend
asked me that question one day
and i felt really defensive and like she
had like really vulnerable when she
asked me
and i thought i thought i was happy and
i still think i was in that moment but
there's something about that question
which really strips you to your essence
so like i think it's it's very nicely
framed as well i like the way you asked
it and i like the silence around it
because it's often that thing of like
conversation
is that the pace is a bit too it's too
quick we're filling silences
and actually something you kind of sit
with am i happy
you know and listeners it's almost
impossible that you want to answer that
question
and if you're not know that that's okay
because it's gonna change
and you know
happiness i think is about like that
it's the base state isn't it it's that
thing of you know what's your base state
what's what's going on with you are you
a happy person generally are you able to
um deal with the stimulus of life
and still maintain
i suppose i need to put a question in
the right question okay
thank you please excuse my terrible
partnership do we do the question on how
or do you uh after i'm going to come and
give you the book and then you scribble
the question thank you so much
my pleasure hey
[Music]
[Music]
you